certainly does kirsten this morning we
learned that big bright tackle trent
brown was placed on the nfl's covet
watch list
which would indicate that either tested
positive for the coronavirus or someone
near him
was positive so he'll miss sunday's game
also today i'll tell you what that virus
though
transmittable so transmittable those who
around brown are also being forced into
isolation at today's press conference
john gruden revealed that not only was
trent brown sent home to quarantine
himself
but that the entire raiders offensive
line was sent home for
contact tracing because of their close
contact with brown
well we're listening to the league and
they're advising us on what to do trent
brown is not here today
his status is unknown we had to send
five of our starting lineman home today
because they had a tracer i guess they
were around
trent i can't get into things any more
than that but
hopefully we'll get some players back
tomorrow or for sunday
it ranks number one in the weirdest
things and i've
y'all know we've seen a lot of weird
things around here in my seven years
but this is definitely up there with
some of the weirdest things i've ever
seen
all right now the player status at this
point unknown sunday's game also in
question
the nfl has already moved games from one
day to another that might happen with
the raiders and bucks game on sunday
night
also today raider safety jonathan abram
was sent home as part of the co-bid
tracing
brown and the rest of the team practiced
monday they had tuesday off gruden
is still hoping for that good news that
he'll have enough players on the line to
play a game
on sunday kirsten